hallöchen liebe freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft galaxy wir noch zusammen
mit den beiden voll speisten hallo herr
hahaha ich meist nicht die ganze zeit
hier ab los wenn du einmal für am anfang
schon wieder wenn du stirbst
runtergefallen bin ja hier stört das
aber super gemacht
du lebst du bist du schon unten
eine fledermaus ist wir sind auf der
suche nach leder aus das ist damit ich
mich vor in kraft ist eine fledermaus
kessel jeder muss hier welche davon
schlagmann noch keine ich freue mich
noch ganz zurück ich sitze neben dir ich
verwende mich mal ganz gut wieder
einfach irgendwas was da schicken
ich suche mir drin was ihnen blüht es
tut mir auch nicht dachte doch direkt in
die hier mein schwert denn die leute die
angeblich alle fakten richtig
ausgetrieben
die hat ihr heftig gegeben ich kann
fliegen wo willst du denn
ich hab's nicht so schnell kriegt jetzt
auch besser als jemals in meinem leben
passiert ist muss ich als etwas erreicht
sein
ich habe richtig kalt was im galaxy
ich habe ich jetzt ein paar sachen von
mir wird ja immer noch ich möchte
eigentlich möchte bezeichnung gar um
bitte ein exemplar was für ein richtiges
suchte ihr felix hat einfach eine
türklingel wie macht man so heißen
journalisten auch ein stuhl zu machen
ist so einfach nur man dafür dass diese
kommission halte ich weiß nicht
vielleicht hab ich was zu essen irgendwo
schon fast schön hin ich glaube jetzt
ein paar diamanten liga
naja du hast auch du kannst du hast ja
nix bin einfach verhungern herzlich es
die muskeln einfahren
ich werde man die braten kann essen kann
man braucht also ich habe jetzt nur
etwas großzügigen nicht reicht und raten
kann weil ich habe so viel von henderson
spricht alles für mich
wenn man böse ist wird man alt war
verließ sonst du kannst du kannst ja
irgendwie versuchen zu töten was ich
habe vielleicht vielleicht hab ich sogar
noch später habe ich ein schwert für
dich noch ich glaube hier sind sie drin
ja genau ich hab noch ein schwert für
dich das liegt er vor der kiste da die
richtig ich bin richtig der erbärmliche
schavan nachgefragten ich geb's ja
einfach hier ist krieg bei dir person
direkt so haben alle zeit nicht wenig
setzt erweisen markt liegen alter aber
100 nähe gar nichts so sowie laufen
glaube ich würde ich mal gut sagen jedes
der body zu viel kann ich mir kann ich
mit der tomaten bei rispentomaten von
venus das okay das ist die antwort ich
weiß nicht wo ich mache ich mache das so
ich arbeite ein bisschen auf dem feld
und da nehme ich mehrere was dafür
nehmen die tomate sieht und fand die an
da musste sie so viele zombies älter
ich brauche irgendwie was wollte ich mir
jetzt holen also palmroth damit ich mein
haus weiter bauen kann
alles ist schon schon schöne steht auch
so ein bisschen raus es ist schon ein
bisschen beleuchtet wird wird im
vergleich im vergleich zu unserem haus
ist es ist wirklich wunderschön
habt ihr ein haus in der trinationalen
dem hause aardman warum ist mein leben
so weiter was ist das geiles betreibung
kann man nicht wissen wie eine statue
von dir erwartet dass sie ohne spaß egal
ist dass der mitte soll ich dir gleich
eine statue von dir machen ich bin eine
statue von mir haben auf jeden fall aber
so richtig cooler wald so mit steinen
und so weit so ist geht raus mein 7 als
super also meine ganzen doch unser ziel
war auch soweit das war höchste
priorität und ihr schafft es nicht
wir müssen auch schon überleben mit dem
er zeigt war wie gaal ja denn man solle
fliegender in das ist richtig schön
seitdem richtig viel spaß gerade ich
mache jetzt die ganze liga musst bist du
kannst nicht mehr stellen wollte
das ist malta gebracht nackt rum alter
was mich
da ich die ganze zeit in welche richtung
mittelmeer geflogen
keep things gebäude leer ist ich habe
keine ahnung ich bin gleich zurück
er wird sich für eine armee fraktion
gegen infektions gebäude der fall gar
nix die aber glaube ich auch nicht
möglich ja ich habe meinen hut ich glaub
ich hab eine fledermaus sieht man echt
kein 30 schade sollten die mal anders
machen als mein leben recht cool ich
schon die ganze zeit keeper damit nicht
an po oder bekommen ich mir neue
munition für meine waffen machen kann
lukas richtigen seinem film gerade an
der masse richtig kannst deine waffen
verkaufen aber an beide fraktionen also
macht somit quasi ein undercover und
verkaufs einfach eine waffe
nein nein nein ich töte eine fleder ich
täte eine spinne und ich verwandeln mich
einfach in diese spinne und jetzt jetzt
muss ich schnell zurück eine fledermäuse
wegfliegen
also dann aber ich bin nicht gestorben
im skelett ich bin vorne aber ich war
doch schon eine spinne ich habe mich
doch schon eine spinne verwandelt also
dass hier will man merke ja patrick wenn
man einen skipper zombie oder sonstiges
ist das büchlein wird dann wird man dann
angegriffen von den bösen
das habe ich mich auch schon gefragt
du meinst du privat ist ob ich dann auch
andere creep attackieren ja das ist so
freund bin da ist man als fährt
schneller
also du kannst am tag auf jeden fall
brennan wenn das gestein gesprengt
das übersehen entfernen gedrückt das war
für ihn denn das ist unser weg wie kann
man aus versehen den herren drücken
er ist sollte neben jesus nie um geld
drehten im enterprise sondern habe ich
außerdem drückt man kann sogar fliegen
essen erklärt konstantin wenn du nicht
sicher bist du bist der könig leuten
applaus
wo seid ihr bei fox tritt über foxtrott
und gimpel bei denen ich bin doch so ein
vollidiot ich habe dieses ganze
gunpowder was ich immer gefunden haben
die eingesammelt mazal war aber eher
überlegt so weit ist die die oberste
regel weisen aber das ist der becher
geschafft das war's halt überlebt das
auch schon viel wenn es nicht viel ich
wollte ich wollte extra noch so schön
munition machen
aber nein walter wo bist du bin bei dem
haus bei deiner stadt marl die
wundersame sonne wanderhure erstmal
dienen dem team das mal da ich will gar
keinem team alter denn die man wieder
ein eigenes team kennen
ich will ich will ich mir sachen haben
ich finde ich will einfach hier raus ist
den fraktions durch wird gekämpft und
zombies komme zumal sich
du kannst auch zu unserer facto hätte
sich zu uns alle fraktionen worten
können die sonne geht jetzt aber auch
gerade oft ja ich war er ist stimmt
schließlich ist darüber diese halte ich
bin gleich da heil kommt die insel und
sprachen sie locker die spontan ist
sophie sofie goos shit falls ich sehe
ich keine fehler aus
wer sonst liegt keine feder mausklick
sonnenberg lang perry torkel der
vorkommen wo willst eine statue haben
direkt vor unserem gebäude natürlich vom
hauptgebäude wie macht man die denn
kommen sie mal mit
schon hammer kräften kommt hier ja die
mich überhaupt meinen augen ist noch zu
packen wird vergiftet sterben heute bis
zwei tage
wir ahnen die moves breakdance was ist
mit meinem bein schießt oder garten skin
also ich sehe halt mein skin aber in
holzoptik ja okay gut weil bei mir
funktioniert es nicht sehen die skins
quasi dein ding sieht richtig geiler
meinestadt.de schaltest du ja auch noch
so items reinlegen guck mal da ist
bereinigt liegt einmal kriegt auch
einlegen community finde ich glaube
jetzt einfach online tomate oder latte
ich weiß geld gemacht bin einfach
draußen gestorben wegen der sonne
du kannst dich wirklich am anfang von
dieser aufnahme allgemein nicht zu
sterben keine scheiße
soll ich nach hause und kommen wieder
was zu essen für mich auch jetzt zu
essen ich ja doch auch hier passt eben
ich habe ein bisschen jubel ist
volkschor januar beiden sucht jetzt
einfach was zuerst okay malte in der
kiste von mir aus gesehen ganz links die
gerade offen ist das kohle drin
ja habe ich das schon eingepackt das war
perfekt in die nähe von funktionsgebäude
wir sind kommt einfach alle zu mir erst
mal sammeln wenn aus dem gebäude raus
geht's links sondern über eine
provisorische brücke dann wird uns schon
so zwei verrichtet wurde hier war was am
flügel sind wir quasi ich bin einzigen
team ist aber trotzdem beide bei mir
etwas zu essen
neben nummer eins zeigt such mal ein
bisschen kann mama ich hab so viele
unnütze scheiße ich habe keine ahnung wo
ich das alles hin packen soll ich habe
eine jedem scrubs kiste ich gehe über
diese dort brücke
lass mal bitte wasserrutsche machen
einfach nicht mehr funktioniert so viel
spaß gemacht
dafür war auch so viel angepflanzt und
strawberry und so was alles da könnt ihr
euch auch mal gleich was machen
man kann sich auch irgendwie so
cocktails machen habe ich gehört habe
richtig viel hier andere pflanzen sind
einfach auch so viel wut mit wir das ist
wichtig denn du bist du nie da hinten
auf diesem berg da in meiner statur
ja genau so eine art brücke ja okay ich
komme ich hoffe ich komme ich bin schwul
hausen oder so ich werde euch einfach
ich habe ich einfach selbst getötet wie
keines lasten die teams lassen aber
unvergleichlich so der übelste stehe die
union nicht mit meinem einfach mit
meiner klara abknallen naja ich sterbe
nicht mehr aus der luft ab wenn du mich
trifft war dadurch komme erst mal ich
muss erstmal umsatzrückgangs um
abrüstung macht ja fast schon ein macht
ihn doch was macht ihr den schritt die
dir dass du dich viel wie bitte aber die
tropfen deshalb fünf heads up richtig
essen ein
das tut richtig weh aber das ist ja
nichts habe
du bist in einer partei also ist alles
legitim schwierig an wieder schon hinter
mir fliegt du bist du denn jetzt ich hab
so angst vor denen es eine fehlerlose
disney micky epic eine fledermaus hat
mich einmal und die krise google ab bist
bist du dass ihr müsst jetzt was zu
essen beschaffen
ich werd bitte ein schock wenn dir gegen
meine schneider ich hoffe nicht dass das
neue diese folge wer kann da war so ein
stück scheiße eingegriffen habe
ja aber ich habe mir nur noch drei
behaltet gerechnet erhält man endlich
die items wenn man ach nee dann kommt so
ein grabsteine nach dem konzert bauen
kann jeder fahren
ich bin ja jetzt schon mal gestorben
vielleicht finde ich ja irgendwo auch so
dass ich kann mein alltag wieder finden
also habe ich noch hoffnung dass der gut
60 minuten reichen